my name is tim dousset I'm an amateur
astronomer
and I'm also legally blind kind of an
oxymoron isn't it it turns out I can
actually see the night sky better than
most people probably better than you
when I was younger it's it's easy to
become discouraged you know realizing
that you're never going to drive a car
that you'll never be an astronaut at
least that's what you're told I was born
with congenital cataracts they remove
the lenses of my eyes and widen my
pupils that left me with only about 10%
of my eyesight for the average person
their pupil automatically adjusts for
the amount of light coming in it opens
and closes but for me my pupil is open
so it's always letting in a lot of light
during the day I see everything
extremely bright everything is
overexposed colors are more vivid
but at nighttime the tables are turned
and it's like a curtain has been lifted
when I was a teenager I went on some
additional surgery to improve my
eyesight I got home from the hospital
and I looked up at the sky and at first
I thought I was actually having a
detached retina I was seeing millions of
spots of light and realized that that
was the Milky Way I was looking at and
it was phenomenal
at first I didn't really realize what it
had given me
I took 15 years later to realize that
what I had was special with my personal
savings I built an observatory on a hill
near my house and called it deep sky I
when I'm looking through a telescope I'm
not wearing my glasses and my eye is
like a camera without a lens so it's
focusing the light very clearly onto my
retina I see a little bit extra light
that most people would see you know you
look at the Orion Nebula and you know it
looks like a fuzzy patch but you know I
kind of get a little bit of purplish
tinge to it the sky here is like a
tapestry of interstellar dust it looks
like a velvet background you know with
diamonds all through it it's absolutely
amazing
my wife is also legally blind
she doesn't see very well at night but
most of the time when we're you know
walking or at the observatory I'll
explain to my wife what I'm seeing she
appreciates the night sky even though
she doesn't see it very well when I
looked through the telescope or look up
at the night sky makes you realized
really that all your problems with fact
that you're legally blind or or whatever
it really just doesn't matter you
realize that you're a part of this
universe
you